many lawmakers are tonight pushing for a
spot at the decision-making table on
possible military action chief
congressional correspondent Mike Emanuel
tells us about that effort to get
President Trump to seek new permission
for a fight some Democrats are
reiterating their call for Congress to
vote on military action in Syria as
veterans we know our nation must
consider purposefully and deliberately
the actions taken by our military
there's not a clear task that we're
giving to our troops they can't tell us
where this is going but House Speaker
Paul Ryan's among those insisting
President Trump already has the power to
respond to atrocities by the Syrian
regime in authorizations for the use of
military force created after the 9/11
attacks what I would hate to do in this
time when we have asymmetric threats all
across the globe particularly with Isis
is to have an AUMF that short that ties
the hands of our military behind their
backs
defense secretary Jim mattis argued the
president would be justified with two
thousand ground troops in Syria to act
in self-defense a Hawaii House Democrat
challenged mattis on the issue while
you're correct in saying the president
has not yet made a decision my question
is will he abide by the Constitution and
comply with the law I believe that the
president will carry out his duties
under the Constitution to protect the
country a Republican member who's a
Marine Corps Iraq war veteran says
Congress should do its duty Madison made
it clear yesterday that the
administration doesn't feel that they
need the authority I disagree I think
that's a misreading of the Constitution
which only gives the executive branch
the authority to repeal sudden attacks I
also think we've strained the 9/11 AUMF
to its breaking point
but a frequent GOP critic of the
president gave him a little flexibility
on this issue it depends on the type of
action if it's a one-off
you know missile strike
you can argue that it doesn't but any
sustained effort yes
would would require an AUMF some in
Congress don't seem to want to debate
and vote on a new authorization it is
quite possible they don't want to own it
if there are negative consequences in
Syria right my commander will love on
the hill Mike thanks